>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
YOU CAN QUESTION WHETHER
JOE BIDEN ACTUALLY GOT, WHAT THE
NUMBER, 81 MILLION VOTES IN THE
LAST PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION IN
ACTION LATER IN THE SHOW WE
WILL.
BUT EVEN IF YOU ACCEPT THERE
ACTUALLY WERE PEOPLE WHO VOTED
FOR JOE BIDEN VOLUNTARILY, IT'S
HARD TO BELIEVE THAT MANY OF
THEM GOT ANYTHING LIKE WHAT THEY
EXPECTED IN RETURN FOR THEIR
VOTES.
JOE BIDEN, NOT TO BE DARK ABOUT
IT JUST HONEST, JOE BIDEN HAS
TURNED OUT TO BE AN UNPARALLELED
DISASTER.
IT IS NOT AN OVERSTATEMENT AND
IT IS A GENEROUS ASSESSMENT.
OUR COUNTRY HAS EVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE JOE BIDEN HAS
DONE.
BARELY 15 MONTHS INTO HIS FIRST
TERM AS PRESIDENT, JOE BIDEN HAS
CRASH THE STOCK MARKET, PROVOKED
A FOOD SHORTAGE, OPENED OUR
BORDERS TO MILLIONS OF ILLEGAL
ALIENS, PRESIDED OVER HISTORIC
RISES IN MURDER, INFLATION, AND
DRUG ODs, AS WELL AS A
CORRESPONDING PLUNGE AND OVERALL
LIFE EXPECTANCY.
AND THEN BECAUSE ALL OF THAT
WASN'T PUNITIVE ENOUGH FOR A
COUNTRY AS RACIST AS OURS, HE
DRAGGED THE UNITED STATES INTO
AN ENTIRELY POINTLESS WAR WITH A
NUCLEAR ARMED POWER ON BEHALF OF
A CORRUPT FOREIGN GOVERNMENT
THAT ONCE BRIBED HIS DRUG
ADDICTED SON.
THAT'S ALL REAL.
JOE BIDEN DID ALL OF THAT.
AND THOSE ARE JUST THE BIG, EASY
TO MEASURE CRIMES HE HAS
COMMITTED.
WE SPENT VIRTUALLY EVERY NIGHT
CATALOGUING SOME OF THE REST,
SHUTTERED SCHOOLS, PERMANENT
LOOTING, LATIN AMERICAN LEVELS
OF WEALTH INEQUALITY, TAMPONS IN
THE BOYS BATHROOM.
$7 A GALLON GASOLINE,
UNPRECEDENTED RACE HATRED,
HOMELESSNESS, MENTAL ILLNESS,
SUICIDE.
IT ABOVE IT ALL ACROSS THE
PACIFIC OCEAN, A CHINESE
GOVERNMENT THAT IS LAUGHING OUT
LOUD AS WE DESTROY OURSELVES FOR
NO REASON.
THAT IS SOME OF WHAT JOE BIDEN
HAS DONE SO FAR.
WE PROMISED A RETURN TO NORMAL.
HE HAS DELIVERED WAR AND
ECONOMIC COLLAPSE.
JOE BIDEN IS OLD ENOUGH
UNFORTUNATELY TO ALMOST NEVER
CERTAINLY BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR ANY OF WHAT HE HAS DONE BUT
HIS PARTY SHOULD BE.
HOW WILL ANY DEMOCRAT OUTSIDE
WEST HOLLYWOOD EVER GET ELECTED
IN THIS COUNTRY AGAIN?
IN A FULLY FUNCTIONING
DEMOCRACY, THAT WOULD BE AN
HONEST QUESTION.
BUT BIDEN HAS A PLAN.
TURK OF THE FEAR, THEY I'M
COMPLAINING, CRIMINALIZE THE
OPPOSITION.
JUST 24 HOURS AGO, JOE BIDEN,
PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES, TOLD
US PEOPLE WHO DON'T SUPPORT HIM
OF THE SINGLE BIGGEST SECURITY
THREAT THAT FACES THIS COUNTRY.
NOT AL QAEDA.
NOT THE CHINESE MILITARY, NOT
THE MEXICAN DRUG CARTELS, NOT
EVEN RUSSIA, WHICH WE ARE TOLD
DAILY IS THE WELLSPRING OF ALL
EVIL.
NO, YOU.
YOU ARE THE BIGGEST THREAT
BECAUSE YOU DON'T VOTE DEMOCRAT.
AS JOE BIDEN PUT IT, "THIS MAGA
CROWD IS REALLY THE MOST EXTREME
POLITICAL ORGANIZATION THAT HAS
EXISTED IN AMERICAN HISTORY."
THE MOST EXTREME, THE WORST.
WORSE THAN THE CLAN, THE NAZIS,
THAN THE ANARCHIST MURDERED AN
AMERICAN PRESIDENT, THAT IS YOU,
YOU ARE AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT
TO THE COUNTRY YOU WERE BORN IN.
IT IS HARD TO BELIEVE JOE BIDEN
SAID THAT.
BUT HE DID SAY IT.
AND OF COURSE, SOME PEOPLE
BELIEVED HIM.
HERE'S WHAT THE SUPREME COURT
LOOKS LIKE TONIGHT.
YOU WILL NOTICE THE RIOT GRADE
SECURITY FENCING AROUND THE
BUILDING.
WHY IS IT THERE?
IT IS THERE TO PROTECT THE
JUSTICES INSIDE FROM THE MOBS
THAT JOE BIDEN HAS INCITED WITH
THE DEMAGOGUERY YOU JUST HEARD.
SAMUEL ALITO IS A 72-YEAR-OLD
LEGAL SCHOLAR WHOSE VIEWS WOULD
HAVE BEEN CONSIDERED ORDINARY
AND MAINSTREAM MAYBE FIVE YEARS
AGO.
NOW, ACCORDING TO JOE BIDEN, HE
IS A DANGEROUS EXTREMIST, HE IS
A MEMBER OF A MOVEMENT MORE
THREATENING THAN ANY POLITICAL
MOVEMENT IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
WHAT'S THE RESULT?
WELL, TODAY, ALITO HAD TO CANCEL
A PUBLIC APPEARANCE BECAUSE
THERE WERE TOO MANY THREATS ON
HIS LIFE.
FOR EACH ONE OF THOSE THREATS IS
IN FACT A THREAT TO US AND OUR
COUNTRY.
YOU DON'T WANT TO LIVE IN A
COUNTRY WHERE SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES COWER IN FEAR FOR THEIR
LIVES IF THEY REACH THE WRONG
CONCLUSION.
THAT IS THE DEFINITION OF A
FAILED STATE.
TURNS OUT WE HAVE A JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT THAT EXIST TO PREVENT
THINGS LIKE THIS FROM HAPPENING.
THAT IS THE WHOLE POINT.
THAT UNDER JOE BIDEN THE DOJ IS
TOO BEHOLDEN TO THE MOB TO SAY A
WORD ABOUT IT.
YOU CAN'T OFFEND ANTIFA, THEY
ARE A VITAL CONSTITUENCY.
HERE IS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
MERRICK GARLAND APPEARING TO
TELL US WHAT HE IS WORRIED ABOUT
MOST.
WATCH.
>> CONSISTENT WITH THE
PRESIDENT'S EXECUTIVE ORDER ON
TACKLING THE CLIMATE CRISIS AT
HOME AND ABROAD, WE ARE ISSUING
A COMPREHENSIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ENFORCEMENT STRATEGY.
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR, INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES, AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OFTEN BEAR THE BRUNT
OF THE HARM CAUSED BY
ENVIRONMENTAL CRIME, POLLUTION,
AND CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> Tucker: WELCOME OF COURSE.
THE GREAT KNOW MY GREATEST
THREAT IS GLOBAL WARMING, WHICH
BY THE WAY IS RACIST LIKE SO
MANY OTHER WEATHER PATTERNS.
THAT IS WHAT MERRICK GARLAND IS
MOST AFRAID OF TONIGHT, AND OF
COURSE, IN ORDER TO FIX GLOBAL
WARMING WHICH IS EXISTENTIAL!
WHATEVER THAT MEANS.
YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE TO HAND
MERRICK GARLAND AND JOE BIDEN A
LOT MORE POWER OVER YOUR LIFE.
SORRY.
THAT IS THE ONLY SOLUTION.
MUCH MORE ON THAT TO COME.
BUT FOR NOW, HERE'S WHAT YOU
SHOULD KNOW.
MERRICK GARLAND DIDN'T EVEN
MENTION THE THREAT, THE PHYSICAL
THREAT TO THIS COUNTRY'S HIGHEST
COURT BECAUSE THOSE THREATS COME
FROM THE LEFT AND THEREFORE
AREN'T REALLY THREATS.
SEE HOW THAT WORKS?
YOU ARE ABOUT TO SEE MORE OF IT.
A LEFT-WING ACTIVIST GROUP IS
NOW PUBLISHED WHAT IT SAYS ARE
THE HOME ADDRESSES OF JUSTICES
AMY CONEY BARRETT, JOHN ROBERTS,
SAMUEL ALITO, BRETT KAVANAUGH,
CLARENCE THOMAS, NEIL GORGES.
QUOTE MIKE "WE MUST RISE UP TO E
ACCOUNTABILITY USING A DIVERSITY
OF TACTICS" EXPLAINS THE GROUP'S
WEBSITE, A DIVERSITY OF TACTICS.
WHAT ARE THOSE >> President
Biden: YOU CAN IMAGINE THEY
ALREADY INCLUDE DISRUPTING
CATHOLIC CHURCH SERVICES.
NOT A BIG DEAL.
IN ORDER TO CHANGE IS THE PRIM
COURT, THAT IS NOT AN ATTACK ON
DEMOCRACY OR ANYTHING,
MERRICK GARLAND IS NOT
CONCERNED.
NOW IF SOMEONE WERE TO
VEHEMENTLY CRITICIZE OPRAH, THAT
WOULD BE DIFFERENT.
A PRESS CONFERENCE ON THE
NATIONAL GUARD.
BUT THE SUPREME COURT JUSTICES,
THEY DESERVE WHAT THEY GOT.
AND SO, UNDER THESE CONDITIONS,
VIOLENCE IS ALREADY BEGINNING.
ABORTION LUNATICS JUST
VANDALIZED A CHURCH IN COLORADO.
SAME THING HAS HAPPENED TO A
PRO-LIFE COUNSELING CENTER IN
PORTLAND.
IN LOS ANGELES DEMONSTRATORS
THREW ROCKS AT COPS FOR SOME
REASON.
WHAT DID THEY HAVE DO TO DO WITH
IT?
WHO KNOWS.
WAR ON THE SYSTEM AND THE
INJURED ONE OF THEM.
BUT MERRICK GARLAND ISN'T
WORRIED ABOUT ANY OF THAT.
HIS FELLOW DEMOCRATS SUPPORT
THAT.
THEY ARE CALLING FOR IT.
THEY LONG HAVE.
HERE IS CHUCK SCHUMER FROM TWO
YEARS AGO THREATENING MOB ACTION
IF ANY SUPREME COURT JUSTICE
WERE EVER TO GET OUT OF LINE.
WATCH THIS.
>> I WANT TO TELL YOU, GORSUCH,
I WANT TO TELL YOU, KAVANAUGH,
YOU HAVE UNLEASHED A WHIRLWIND
AND YOU WILL PAY THE PRICE.
YOU WON'T KNOW WHAT HIT YOU IF
YOU GO FORWARD WITH THESE AWFUL
DECISIONS.
>> Tucker: YOU WILL PAY THE
PRICE?
REALLY?
THESE ARE PEOPLE WITH LIFETIME
APPOINTMENTS, SO HOW EXACTLY
COULD THEY PAY THE PRICE?
WE CAN'T VOTE AGAINST THEM.
WHAT CAN WE DO?
WE CAN HURT THEM.
WE CAN HARASS THEIR FAMILIES.
WE CAN MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE TO
LIVE IN THIS COUNTRY THROUGH
THREATS OF VIOLENCE.
"YOU WON'T KNOW WHAT HIT YOU"
SAID THE THUG FROM NEW YORK.
APPARENTLY THEY ARE ABOUT TO
LEARN WHAT IS GOING TO HIT THEM.
REMEMBER WHEN LIBERALS USE TO
OPPOSE VIOLENCE?
THEY DID.
GIVE PEACE A CHANCE.
IT IS HARD TO BELIEVE THERE WAS
EVER A TIME THAT WAS TRUE.
MAYBE THEY'RE JUST PRETENDING.
IN ANY CASE, THEY ARE NOT
FOREIGN.
VIOLENCE IS THE RELIGION.
HERE AND ABROAD.
YOU ARE SEEING IT ON DISPLAY
RIGHT IN FRONT OF YOU WHETHER
YOU HAVE NOTICED OR NOT.
IN EASTERN EUROPE.
SO RATHER THAN TRYING TO SAVE A
CIVILIAN POPULATION OF
EASTERN EUROPE, JOE BIDEN IS
PUSHING FOR A HOT WAR AGAINST
RUSSIA.
IN FACT, HE IS ALREADY ENGAGED
IN A HOT WAR AGAINST RUSSIA AND
SO ARE WE WHETHER WE KNOW IT OR
NOT.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" JUST RAN
THIS HEADLINE, "U.S.
INTELLIGENCE IS HELPING UKRAINE
KILL RUSSIAN GENERALS."
OH, NO BIG DEAL.
PARTY FOR THE PAPER, "THE
UNITED STATES PROVIDED
INTELLIGENCE ABOUT RUSSIAN UNITS
THAT HAS ALLOWED UKRAINIANS TO
TARGET AND KILL MANY OF THE
RUSSIAN GENERALS WHO DIED IN
ACTION IN UKRAINE MORE,"
ACCORDING TO SENIOR AMERICAN
OFFICIALS.
SO THEY ARE BRAGGING ABOUT IT.
AND NOT JUST THAT THEY ARE
NBC NEWS REPORTS BIDEN OFFICIALS
ARE ALSO BRAGGING ABOUT HELPING
TO SHOOT ONLY RUSSIAN TRANSPORT
PLANE CARRYING HUNDREDS OF
RUSSIAN TROOPS, AND THEN
TONIGHT, SINCE BEING HERE,
TONIGHT THE ADMINISTRATION
IS SAYING OUT LOUD IT IS TO
HELP SINK A RUSSIAN WARSHIP.
WHY ARE THEY DOING THIS?
MORE BAFFLING, WHY ARE THEY
TAKING CREDIT FOR IT IN PUBLIC?
WHY WOULD YOU TELL PEOPLE YOU
ARE DOING THAT?
THERE IS ONLY ONE REASON BECAUSE
YOU WANT WAR WITH RUSSIA
MORE AGAINST NUCLEAR ARMED
COUNTRIES IS HARD TO IMAGINE.
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN ONE.
THERE IS NO REASON TO HAVE A WAR
LIKE THIS THERE DOES NOT NEED TO
HAVE NO MIGHT BE A WAR LIKE
THIS.
BIDEN WANTS IT.
WE ARE NOT IMAGINING THAT, HE IS
TELLING US WHAT HE IS DOING.
WE ARE JUST IGNORING.
MANY DEMOCRATS ARE TELLING US
WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
BIDEN ALLIE CONGRESSMAN OF
MASSACHUSETTS SAYING OUT LOUD ON
FOX ON MONDAY.
WATCH.
>> AS THEY WRAP THIS IN THE
SENATE WITH UKRAINE FUNDING IN
COVID FUNDING, YOU GUYS OKAY
WITH THAT?
>> I SUPPORT IT BECAUSE IT IS
THE RIGHT THING TO DO FOR
UKRAINE.
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A LOT OF
POLITICS INVOLVED AND THERE WILL
BE DOMESTIC DEBATES AT HOME
ABOUT POLICIES AND WHATNOT BUT
AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE HAVE
TO REALIZE WE ARE AT WAR AND NOT
JUST NETWORK TO SUPPORT UKRAINE
FROM WE ARE FUNDAMENTALLY AT WAR
ALTHOUGH IT IS SOMEWHAT THROUGH
PROXY WITH RUSSIA AND IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE WIN.
>> Tucker: REALLY?
WE ARE AT WAR.
DID YOU KNOW THAT?
THAT THEY TEXT YOU TO LET YOU
KNOW?
BECAUSE WARS TEND TO ESCALATE
AND WARS THAT ARE EXISTENTIAL
FROM ONE SIDE IN WHICH THE
LEADER OF THE COUNTRY FEELS HE
MAY DIE IF HE LOSES TEN TO
ESCALATE VERY QUICKLY.
OBVIOUSLY.
SETH MOULTON IS NOT WORRIED, IT
IS JUST IMPORTANT WE WIN, HE
TELLS US.
WE, WHO IS WE?
AND IMPORTANT TO WHOM, EXACTLY?
IS THERE ANYONE OUTSIDE
WASHINGTON WHO WANTS A REAL WAR
WITH NUCLEAR ARMS RUSSIA?
WHO EXACTLY IS SETH MOULTON
TALKING ABOUT WHEN HE SAYS WE?
WE WERE WONDERING AND THEN WE
WATCHED BIDEN YESTERDAY, HE
TRAVELED TO ALABAMA AND MICHIGAN
MIKE VISITED THE ONLY
CONSTITUENCY IN AMERICA THAT
LONGS FOR WAR WITH NUCLEAR ARMS
RUSSIA AND THAT WOULD BE HIS
DONORS.
HE TOURED A LOCKHEED MARTIN
PLANT AND AS HE DID BIDEN POSTED
WE ARE SENDING SO MANY WEAPONS
TO UKRAINE THAT MOTHERS IN THE
UNITED STATES ARE NAMING THEIR
CHILDREN AFTER LOCKHEED MARTIN'S
MISSILE SYSTEMS.
WATCH.
>> WHEN WE BUILD WEAPONS AND
EQUIPMENT TO HELP DEFEND FREEDOM
AND SOVEREIGNTY IN EUROPE YEARS
AGO, THAT'S TRUE AGAIN TODAY,
THE JAVELIN MISSILES
MANUFACTURED HERE.
THEY ARE HIGHLY PORTABLE
COMMENTS FROM THE EFFECTIVE
AGAINST AND WIDE RANGE OF
TARGETS.
TARGETS 400 METERS AWAY.
IN FACT, THERE'S EVEN A STORY
ABOUT UKRAINIAN PARENTS NAMING
THEIR CHILDREN, THEIR NEWBORN
CHILD JAVELIN, NOT A JOKE.
>> Tucker: IT'S A JOKE, JUST A
LITTLE JOKE ABOUT WEAPONS
SYSTEMS.
IT USED TO BE WHEN AMERICAN
PRESIDENTS TALKED ABOUT KILLING
PEOPLE THE FIRST THING THEY DID
WAS MAKE CERTAIN IT WAS ABSENTLY
JUSTIFIED, WE HAVE BEEN IN
BRAIDED, OR HARBOR,
9/11.
THIS IS AN ENTIRELY VOLUNTARY
EXERCISE.
THE SECOND THING THEY DID WAS
ATTACH GRAVITY TO THE IDEA OF
PEOPLE DYING BECAUSE WHEN PEOPLE
DIE IT IS SAD.
THEY LEAVE BEHIND SPOUSES AND
PARENTS AND SIBLINGS AND
CHILDREN.
DEATH IS SAD.
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
THEY DON'T JOKE ABOUT IT.
JOE BIDEN CONSIDERS THAT AN
UPLIFTING STORY.
JOE BIDEN IS DEMENTED AND HE IS
DANGEROUS AND SO ARE THE PEOPLE
WHO WORK FOR HIM.
THAT IS TRUE.
SORRY TO SAY IT OUT LOUD BU